[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where I can't waste any more time
getting to the finale of this theory
because I keep literally being stopped
in the streets and asked what the
deadliest movie is gonna end up being
it's actually a little unsettling how
into this theory everyone is plus the
process of getting through these last
five excruciating ly historically
inaccurate movies is gonna take us so
long that I literally don't have any
time to waste today no witty banter no
cringy dad jokes just death death and
even more death remember we ended last
episode with our total kill count
sitting at three thousand five hundred
and twenty I forgot to add in too at the
end of last episode those three thousand
five hundred twenty deaths were coming
across fifty three movies the top of our
deadliest Disney movie leaderboard
belonged to the Lion King sitting
confidently atop Pride Rock and a pile
of bones with 1660 lives lost mostly due
to a half a decade of hyenas overfeeding
but get ready because today's
challengers are gonna give that number a
heck of a run for its money when we
started in on this trilogy everyone on
our theorist team picked the movie that
they thought was gonna end up being the
deadliest it's like guessing the weight
of a new baby before it's born except
instead of Powell's announces its
beheadings and extinction-level events
hopefully your pick made it as a
finalist because this is your last
chance to get those bets in your final
five Internet
Mulan dinosaur Hercules Atlantis or
Moana okay maybe it's just gonna stay
the Lion King choose wisely because
lives and more importantly internet
bragging rights depend on let's start
with what is bizarrely the most
straightforward of these final five
Mulan which was a clear fan favorite for
death count in the comments and I
understand why I mean you literally see
two villages burned an army of good guys
just outright dead in the snow and the
climax of the whole thing is as we all
remember Mulan using fireworks to cause
an avalanche that buries all but six of
the invading Han army initially I
thought the best way to do this would be
to just look at history
Mulan the Disney movie in case you
didn't know comes from the Chinese
legend of Guam LAN where the fee
warrior Mulan does what the movie would
teach us to expect her to do she takes
her aging father's place in the army to
defend against invaders
interestingly enough though this is a
really progressive story in the original
legend she doesn't hide her true self
from her family or sneak away in the
middle of the night her family totally
supports her decision to become a
kick-butt warrior woman but she doesn't
even need to fall in love with another
soldier I mean I get that Disney needed
to create some conflict or something but
the 5th century historical version of
this story is actually a lot cooler and
a lot more progressive than the 1998
remake feels bad man given that it's a
legend maybe based in some history I
thought we could estimate deaths based
on the number of soldiers and Shen use
real army but genu isn't a real person
if anyone he's sort of super loosely
based on Attila the Hun but
geographically atilla's Empire ended
3,000 miles west of the Northern Wei
Empire where the Mulan legend originates
and most of his battles were fought
against Europeans so we got ourselves
the wrong enemy at the wrong end of the
continent so there were really no attila
battles that i could base this on but i
kept on trying shen you gets his name
from the anglicized version of shan you
title which is just the generic term for
a Hunley der it would be like watching a
movie about America a thousand years
from now where the head of our country
was somehow named Perez Odin given that
Shawn you is this totally generic title
there is still no battle that we could
possibly base this finale of Mulan on it
also doesn't help us that there's no
real historical record of lon
while her legend is really famous she's
usually left out of Chinese history
texts and seems to be treated like a
symbol rather than a real historical
person so in the end with not enough
credible information to go on
I had to result in doing a death count
ooh the old-fashioned way counting
except that counting all these people
the old-fashioned way would have taken a
ridiculous amount of time so I did it
the new fashioned way a macro using
canoe active I processed the frames of
Mulan to automatically count how large
Shen use Ford was the program converts
the images into black and white which in
turn makes it easier for
computer to count the individual members
of the army I had to really fiddle
around with the settings here to make
sure that the program only was counting
what I wanted it too soon to be dead hon
after some creative photoshopping I came
out with eleven deaths on the
mountainside by aggressive firework plus
an additional hundred and seventy-eight
horsemen and 1048 other soldiers in the
Avalanche itself for a grand total of
1237 kills
add to that the two villages that we see
burned which based on the size and
proximity to the Great Wall of China
would have had about a hundred residents
each as well as the army that gets
massacred trying to surprise a tech
shinu which we can count in these scenes
to be 31 but actually only adds 30
deaths since one messenger survives the
massacre how many men does it take to
deliver a message and then shenyu
himself we get ourselves a grand total
of 1468 it's worth noting here that I've
seen a few other different versions of
this death count circulating around
online ranging anywhere from two hundred
and sixty to the upwards of 2,000 I was
absolutely exhaustive in this analysis
as possible so I feel pretty darn good
about that 1468 number but in the end it
still doesn't edge out Lion King with
Mulan out of the way it's time to move
on to the last of our movies in the
princess category going from Mulan in
China ish to Moana in Polynesia ish
after this it's all God's and natural
disasters so mallanna is gonna be our
last hope for a princess to take home
the murder crown rabbit allah becomes
death number one early on in the movie
and death number two quickly skyrockets
to death number 260 when Maui and Moana
blow up and sink an entire society of
cogs Laura the little coconut pirates
they meet and that totally forgettable
scene that's just sandwiched in the
middle of the movie anyway those little
scamp's are based on a solomon islands
legend of the Camorra
a race of very small people who would
steal from Island tribes they're always
depicted as cute harmless which is
clearly why Moana and Maui feel it
necessary to sink 259 of them at my best
count mercilessly into the ocean and
then smile about it to each other as
they say
leaving no survivors in their weight
virutal okay that's 260 it's certainly a
bloodbath but it is far from
record-breaking but now we get to the
curse the whole movie hinges on the fact
that Maui stole this powerful heart of
defeat II and thereby brought about a
thousand-year plague without her heart
if city began to crumble giving birth to
a terrible darkness that will continue
to spread until every one of us is
devoured that means that Maui would be
responsible for a thousand years of
Darkness spreading across the Pacific
Islands which seems like it should be a
shoo-in for death and destruction
I am certainly excited now we do have to
remember that except for a single crab
god animal species aren't sapient in
this movie so fish aren't gonna count
and as much as I'd like to think that
that leaves us with plenty of room for
death the problem with this curse
quickly becomes the fact that it's just
now showing up to mallanna's island
which means that it has been coming for
a long time
sure grandma's map at the beginning of
the movie shows this darkness spreading
really fast
and yet when Moana and her dad visit the
top of the island he shows her how long
they've been living there without any
issues no darkness to contend with for
at my count twelve generations if we're
being generous and say that a generation
of leader is turning over every 25 years
which again who Ana's dad looks
significantly older than this but we're
giving it a worst-case scenario we're
looking at at least 300 years of easy
fish and coconuts without even a hint of
a plague I mean if you have that long to
become a doomsday prepper and you don't
build in any contingency plans I think
there's an argument to be made that you
might have had it coming anyway the
point is we need to see if this darkness
is actually creeping up on anyone or if
it's just totally avoidable to figure
that out we're gonna have to measure how
far the curse is traveled which we know
is gonna be from the heart of defeat II
where the curse started to mallanna's
Island at the start of the movie so all
we need to know is how far she travels
in her boat between those two locations
and how long it takes to get there
here's what we know we sima wanna travel
for three
four days at most her boat is captained
by Maui a master wayfinder and demigod
and her boat is a recreation of a Fujian
chemical similar to an outrigger canoe
that can travel up to 15 knots or 17
miles per hour we're gonna somehow have
to ignore the fact that this boat was
also built by those three hundred year
old ancestors who landed on mallanna's
Island making this boat so impossibly
old that there's no way it would
actually sail but whatever Disney will
also assume that mallanna didn't sleep
at any point during the journey
something Maui considered a sign of
weakness as a Wayfinder so at the boats
max rate steered completely straight by
an expert wayfinder she could sail 1632
miles or 2626 kilometers in four days
which is pretty incredible but we're
giving them the best-case scenario
this means that mallanna's island is a
little over 1,600 miles from the heart
of 2pt or cursed ground zero okay if the
darkness started at two feeding and is
just now reaching Mona's Island at least
300 years later we're saying that it
took 300 years for the darkness to
spread 1632 miles
meaning that the curse has spread 5.4
miles per year that is nothing when
you're standing on the shore of a beach
the horizon you're seeing is 2.8 miles
away from the top of mallanna's Island
you would be seeing well over 12 miles
into the horizon you would literally see
this darkness coming towards your shores
for several years in advance which is
why mallanna's deadliness just falls
apart with that much notice it would be
almost impossible to believe that
seed-bearing polynesian island dwellers
who primarily fish for a survival would
be unable to you know get in their boats
and sail to the next island over when
they see the curse coming there by
buying them a few extra years even
mallanna's tribe of people who are water
phobic are still gonna have time to see
their shriveled coconuts throw some flex
tape onto those centuries-old boats and
move to the next island which would buy
them more time so the final death tally
from Awana 261 not even close
after a thoroughly disappointing
performance by Moana it's up to the last
three movie
to knock my socks off and I'm confident
in the next to Atlantis the lost Empire
and Hercules
sure Atlantis lost Empire ain't one of
those beloved Disney classics with a big
plastic VHS cover but looking back on it
it's pretty darn good and at the very
least it is pretty darn deadly at this
point that's all I really care about
since it's gonna need to prove itself in
gladiatorial fashion against another
strong challenger from the same part of
the world
Hercules in one corner it got herself a
flood that wrecks an entire civilization
and in the other we have ourselves a
complete war between gods and Titans
with the world of man caught stuck in
the middle so let's set up those dueling
death tickers and get down to it
Atlantis there's a big chase scene with
a Leviathan
early on in the movie that accounts for
171 deaths right off the bat adding in
the King's death and the ending battle
who suddenly jump up to a hundred and
eighty five though it can be hard to
tell how many of the explosions we see
signifying certain death and how many
are just like as I believe is the
technical term of what we're watching
Hercules his kills are mostly taking
place during the montage of him
completing some of the most famous
twelve labors of Hercules Hercules
Hydra 30 man being born in Lyon which
looks suspiciously like Skaar a sea
monster that isn't part of the labors
but we'll give him credit for anyway and
then the Minotaur a Gorgon and some
really scary looking birds two of which
were actually fought by the Greek hero
Perseus but you get the idea we can also
give my dualies credit for killing neces
the Centaur that's torturing Meg it's
unclear in the movie if he's officially
dead or if he's just unconscious but
according to Greek myth Hercules does
indeed kill him so we're gonna go with
that
and know we're not counting make sure
she dies but she has to die and stay
dead meg gets her vibe before the end of
the movie also he can't count Hades
because he already lives in the
underworld so based off of these early
acts
sequences Atlantis the lost Empire has a
significant lead but at the end of the
day this isn't really gonna matter
because these numbers are tiny compared
to the huge catastrophic events in both
movies the sinking of Atlantis and the
technology and here's where the counting
has to get creative Atlantis the lost
Empire starts with a giant tsunami
headed for the island of Atlantis a
protective barrier bubble thing is
formed around the center of the island
and sinks it to the ocean it's not as
though everyone in Atlantis dies but we
do see a lot of people banging on that
bubble from the outside and the bubble
only ends up saving just a small
fraction of the land of Atlantis which
leaves us with an obvious question and
the not so obvious answer how many
people died when Atlantis Saints it'd be
nearly impossible to get a decent guess
at this just from the design of the city
that we see at the beginning of the
movie so we're gonna have to go all the
way back to the ancient Greek Atlantis
story to determine the most likely death
toll ditto for when Hades releases the
Titans onto earth and they start
wrecking house let's start with Atlantis
from a historical perspective all our
information about Atlantis comes from
the Greek philosopher Plato you know the
Plato who tells a story about a farmer
who finds himself a ring that makes him
invisible but corrupts him morally a
story that j.r.r tolkien definitely
didn't steal anyway in his dialogue
Critias Plato tells of the continent
Atlantis a 10,000 BC superpower with a
great military and tons of technology so
advanced that it sank because the gods
got jealous and said a big earthquake
slash flood combo to take it down sounds
fine cool myth bro the Plato never
mentions how many people live on
Atlantis which would have really done a
lot to make my life easier bizarrely the
mythical estimates for Atlantis's army
ranges from 5 million to over 100
million and everything in between
but regardless those numbers give us a
bit of an issue because the population
of the entire world at the time in
10,000 BC would have been somewhere in
the order of 1 to 3 million people
adding in
injury Atlantis probably isn't even from
10,000 BC because a mistranslation
basically changed the entire story to
nine thousand years ago when it was
originally meant to be nine hundred
years ago
so basically TLDR were looking for some
historical event that Plato could have
based his clearly made-up story on that
he then used to pass off as if it were
historically true to all his bros so
what historic clues can we find in
Atlantis the movie well the one thing we
actually know is that there was a
tsunami so we just have to find a
massive historical tsunami at the right
time and place to make this happen and
for that ladies and gentlemen I give you
the Minoan civilization located on the
island of Crete and most prominent from
about 2000 to 1500 BC the Minoans are
most famous for building palaces and
being the inspiration for the myth of
the Minotaur
but Minoans are also our best proxy for
both Atlantis as Plato reported it as
well as how Disney imagined in the large
buildings that we see present in
Atlantis the lost Empire would have been
extraordinarily rare in the ancient
world but the Minoans were building
palaces and multi-story buildings
earlier than any other island
civilization that we know of the Minoan
language also checks off the boxes from
what we see in the movie nobody is
really sure what Minoan sounded like
because we can't read the basic Minoan
writing system known as linear a which
parallels the fact that no one can read
at lanty and in the movie itself yes yes
I can read Atlantean just like you you
can't okay me no one can and most
importantly of all we have an event that
would make sense for the quote-unquote
sinking of Atlantis around 1550 BC right
around the real-time Atlantis was
supposed to be set without Plato
screwing up his dates the volcanic
island of fira modern-day santorini
exploded destroying part of the island
and sending gigantic waves to the shores
of crete only about 70 miles away the
resulting tsunami devastated the coast
of crete destroying cities ruining
coastline and of course killing a lot
people now I hear you Atlantis is
supposed to have sunk into the sea and
creeds is still very much around that
said part of the island of fear Assange
you can actually see where a bunch of it
is missing even to this day so the whole
idea is still right this event sunken
Island and destroyed a civilization so
for God's sake after all of that over
analysis what the heck is the death
count well estimates have the eruption
of Thera killing 35,000 Minoans on crete
Wow that's to say nothing of the people
who are on Fuhrer itself even if we want
to use a more conservative estimate
those estimates still run in the range
of twenty thousand deaths definitely
enough to dwarf any of our other Disney
contenders up to this point so as
devastating a historical event as this
was based on the silver lining here is
that in the Disney version there is no
way if Berkeley's can beat this right I
mean sure houses are crushed temples are
blown away but it can't measure up to
the explosion of fear of rights except
interestingly enough many people believe
that the inspiration for the story of
the titan ama key the exact scenes that
we see take place and hercules was the
massive eruption of Thera the same event
that we just attributed to the loss of
atlantis so the long story short here is
that the destruction in these two movies
are based on the exact same event so
what is it like the tie then I mean
effectively for as much as we can
calculate real numbers out of poorly
documented historical facts that
influenced fictional movies hundreds of
years later yeah although Hercules is
taking place in Thebes which is much
farther away from Fira than krita's so
there would be fewer deaths associated
with Hercules just by proximity alone
there you have it Hercules and Atlantis
practically in a tie I mean of the two
Atlantis would qualify as the more
deadly movie with Hercules in second
place but the two of them have a
commanding lead over anything else in
the Disney canon that we've covered so
far
congratulations Disney on leveraging a
devastating global event for children's
entertainment not just once but twice
don't worry a year yeah a tie what
and lead us through an entire flippin
trilogy on Disney movies and ruined
Christmas and string us along through
this ungodly long episode that has
itself a flippin mid-roll just to tell
us that it ends in a tie I mean I don't
write the movies so take it up with old
Walt oh wait there is still one more
dinosaur that's right the Disney feature
you didn't know you needed and then
definitely continue to not need because
it came out in 2000 and we already had
the far superior Land Before Time series
since 1988 oh regardless it's a movie
that the Disney Animation Studios made
and it is here where the buck stops when
it comes to Disney deaths and I know
you're all like oh of course this movie
shows the extinction right so many
millions of dinosaurs died and as much
as I'd like to just finally finally end
this with the mass extinction of the
dinosaurs this movie actually doesn't
show that event I swear that would have
put the easy way out but in the entire
film only five dinosaurs died two bad
guys two good guys and one neutral
Triceratops that's it I know I couldn't
believe it either
but if that's the case then where else
could all the deaths come from and the
grand answer the answer to where the
most Disney deaths come from in the
animation studios 80-year history isn't
coming from humans isn't coming from
fish it's coming from lemurs yep these
guys prehistoric lemurs he might be
thinking to yourself gee I didn't think
dinosaurs and lemurs really lived at the
same time and right you would be pretty
much there's some research that mammals
and dinosaurs did overlap for a very
short time at the end of the Cretaceous
period when aladar are Iguanodon
protagonist was supposed to have lived
and it just so happens that one of the
oldest animal species to exist in this
teeny overlapping sweet spot 60 million
years ago were lemurs and yes
historically you still have to really
squint at this one to get any kind of
scenario where a monkey family would
raise a dinosaur we're just gonna have
to go with this one in order to make it
to the other side of it like I said very
few dinosaurs were actually harmed in
the making of dinosaurs but an entire
island worth of lemurs were just knocked
out in one fell swoop we
Meteor and the associated fallout land
on the uncreated lee named lemur island
in the movie sending the entire island
up in flames
except for this small lemur family our
friendly dinosaur hero the lemur baby
even comments that during the film
thereby confirming for us that every
lemur on lemur island is now a crispy
critter lot of course that leads to the
next obvious question how in the world
do we know how many that is or even how
big Lemur island is well in the most
bizarre twist of luck we actually know
the real world location of lemur Island
because historically there is only one
possible location it's the real island
off the east coast of Africa called
Madagascar in your biology lesson for
the day the reason lemurs are lemurs is
because they evolved all by themselves
over millions of years isolated from all
other primate species on the lonely
island of Madagascar all lemurs even
modern lemurs started back on Madagascar
so this is literally the only place
lemur Island could be in the entire
planet Earth especially on the order of
60 million years ago when Madagascar had
just started to separate from
continental Africa this is also why we
only see the dinosaur and lemurs
swimming across a narrow channel rather
than a huge body of water in the
aftermath of the meteor strike at the
time they escaped from lemur Island
lemur Island was just recently lemur
Peninsula so with that incredible stroke
of luck we now know not only where lemur
island is but how big it is
Madagascar is 226,000 597 square miles
in area but not all of that area is
habitable by lemurs going by its
modern-day geography which is honestly
all we got only about 43,000 square
miles of the island is rainforest which
is Lemur habitat and also the area where
we see the lemurs living in movies so
how many lemurs could reasonably be
living in 43,000 square miles of jungle
Oh
well this is impossible to know directly
but the lemurs in the movie would have
been precursors to the modern
ring-tailed lemur which has a territory
size of 0.14 square miles that means
that you could fit yourself 307,000 143
lemurs on to Madagascar at territory
capacity which is how many lemurs we
would have the potential to lose in
dinosaurs even if we said it was half
that number if we said it was a dead
that number we still have our winner by
a long shot by an apocalyptic landslide
dinosaur is the deadliest Disney movie
of all time
rest in peace lemurs in a moment of
silence for all the Disney fallen who've
gone before you
[Music]
[Applause]
so after 58 movies and three incredibly
long episodes what does all this mean my
friends we have come a long way on the
Disney death tree I wanted to highlight
how much we've accomplished here by
recapping some of our most significant
findings across the entire Disney canon
58 original Disney animation studio
movies are estimated total deaths are
344 thousand thirty one which is
honestly nothing compared to the number
of childhood dreams this show kills on a
regular basis our overall deadliest
Disney movie winner is dinosaur and a
death count of up to 300,000 sapient
lemurs the most deaths of any movie a
cared about or are likely to have seen
however goes resoundingly to Hercules
and Atlantis lost Empire with over
twenty to thirty thousand deaths each by
volcano most deaths in a Disney princess
movie as well as Disney's deadliest
princess goes to Mulan with just over
1200 very respectable number Disney's
deadliest and most effective villainous
scar from The Lion King at sixteen
hundred and fifty nine deaths 1660 of
Death one's own most twisted deaths go
to Alice in Wonderland where the walrus
eats 12 Easter babies most tragic death
ends up going to the accidentally
harpooned opera singing whale in make my
music just brutally sad and my personal
favorite Disney death goes to Ursula
being stabbed in the stomach at the end
of Little Mermaid and now finally with
this series over and all this being said
you can now go and we can all
collectively kill off 2018 to start the
old kill count back at zero for 2019
this has been an incredibly fun but
totally exhausting project to finish off
the year I hope you enjoyed it as much
as I did this was a blast let me know if
you want to do something similar for
Pixar movies dreamworks movies I don't
know I'm game for anything thank you so
much for your support over this
three-part trilogy thank you so much for
your continued support of film theory
and have a happy new year everyone
onward to 2019 I will see you there with
more
is more film series and cups